[Music]
here we are half brown welcome to the
podcast thank you appreciate appreciate
you making the trip out here I've been
looking forward to this for a long time
you've got a big vision and a huge
mission that I applaud and I'm looking
forward to hearing all about it before
we even get into it though I have to
have to say that I didn't realize until
I started digging in doing some research
for this today that a few months ago you
hired Dennis Woodside as your president
arrival yeah yeah so Dennis I've known
Dennis since like 1993 oh man
we we were summer associates at a law
firm in San Francisco way back in the
day and have remained friends over the
years and I remember working with him
very vividly and I was just struck with
how smart and capable this guy was at a
very young age and somebody who
demonstrated incredible leadership
skills even in this junior position we
were paired together to work on a few
matters and he just took total control
of the situation in a way that I've
never seen in anybody else so I knew way
back then that this guy was destined for
big things and you know he's been at
Google running the Motorola division and
then he was a Dropbox of CEO and now
he's with you which is pretty exciting
yeah we're so so happy to have him I
mean he's he's already made a huge
impact he's a terrific leader a complete
straight shooter you know no BS yeah
yeah and just a great guy he is super
smart and also an incredible iron man
you know that right he's done like 14
iron man's yeah like I know I haven't
III haven't followed his career but but
I've heard that yes yeah cool
so I think the best way to it was just
out training yesterday so was he watch
your back oh yeah trust me I think he's
he's he went like 922 and an iron man I
think he's super fast he's a very good
athlete yeah
let's talk about the mission statement
the why behind impossible food it's sure
well the mission is very simple it's to
completely replace animals in the food
system by 2035 and the why try to keep
it as short as possible but basically
you know I got on the path to founding
it when I realized what I should have
known earlier I wish I did that the use
of animals as a food technology is by a
huge margin the most destructive
technology on earth and really poses a
catastrophic threat and I thought I was
pretty savvy about environmental issues
and you know I had been on a plant-based
diet for a long time so I had no
particular investment in that in that
business but it really came as a
surprise to me when I started looking
for a problem to work on just trying to
figure out what's the what what's the
biggest problems I can contribute to
solving what a humungous disastrous
impact that technology has it's I think
if most people know it's a major source
of greenhouse gases more than all forms
of transportation combined it is the
biggest user of fresh water in the world
the biggest polluter by far fresh water
in the world and it the biggest issue is
that it is occupies a huge land area for
land-based agriculture about 50% of the
entire land surface of Earth is actively
in use right now either growing feed
crops or grazing livestock and that land
footprint comes at the expense of all
the biodiversity that previously
occupied that land and as a result it is
by an overwhelming margin the biggest
cause of this catastrophic meltdown
biodiversity we're experiencing
all practical purposes nothing else
really matters
it's land-based animal agriculture and
overfishing that that are causing this
thing and that is even more of I think
risk to the future of our planet and the
climate change issue and I think people
are increasingly starting to become
aware of it but you know in the past 40
years we've basically wiped out half the
wild animals that were living right back
then and it's just across the board
mammals birds reptiles amphibians fish
even insects and that has happened so
fast and and it's happening it's you
know it's continuing to accelerate
because the driver is the land footprint
of animal agriculture and overfishing
which are the demand for meat and fishes
is growing faster than population and
you know when you take pieces of an
ecosystem out of the ecosystem it's like
you know pulling bricks out of the wall
it's it's extremely destabilizing and
basically won't immediately cause but it
is setting up for a crash and so I don't
think we've even begun to feel the full
impacts of this problem but anyway bla
bla bla bla bla
the when I realize this I felt that okay
this is what I've got to work on and I
also realized that very quickly that
you're not going to solve the problem by
asking people to change their diets
telling them to change their diets
educating them coercing them anything
like that it's never worked it's been
tried every which way yeah you're still
trying though no I there's no reason not
to try yeah but I hear you but I think
you're absolutely right you have to
solve this problem as the you know have
to meet people where they are exactly
you have to run it people where they are
and and you know I mean China which is
used to getting what it wants when it
went ask the citizens for something
asked its citizens to reduce their meat
and dairy consumption by half this was
two or three years ago and what happened
was absolutely nothing the demand didn't
go down it kept going up that's going up
while the rise of the middle class there
is contributing to that and I think Asia
accounts for something like 46% of all
meat consumption yeah Asia as a
continent absolutely it's Asia and
Africa where most of the growth is
happening Asia and particularly because
of the big population and so that's a
big target for us but I think the the
real take-home message though is that
yes I you know I was in education for
most of my life I'm all for education
and I think it's very important for
people to you know understand what's
going on in the world but the people who
understand this problem the most I was
at the cop21 climate conference like
three years ago and you know you have
hundreds of the most dedicated
environmentalists in the world at this
event and literally almost to a person
they went out and had steak for dinner
okay so I think that pretty much tells
you that knowing about the issue caring
about the issue is still not enough to
get people to change what they love in
their diet and so what that meant for me
is that the only way to solve it is to
is to basically frame it as a technology
problem the world is going to continue
to demand these foods but we're making
them the wrong way using incredibly
inefficient and obviously quite
destructive technology that
underperforms in every way that matters
including economics so it's because it's
so inefficient the on a nutritional
basis you know the foods we get from
animals are more than an order of
magnitude more expensive than any
plant-based equivalent that's a huge
opportunity to come up with a new
technology that outperforms in every way
that matters to consumers most
importantly deliciousness but also
nutritional value affordability and so
forth
and I was sure that's completely doable
back then and I'm even more sure now
right so that's how we're gonna solve
the problem right so here we are I mean
the the disconnect and the dissonance is
huge when you look at the statistics as
you said something like 50% of all
arable land on the planet is devoted to
animal agriculture and some respect man
and and a very large fraction of the non
arable land is heavily grace right 14.5
percent of all greenhouse gas emissions
are attributable to animal agriculture
which is basically on parity if not
exceeding transportation which is what
everyone wants to talk about but the the
the mass species extinction is something
that you don't hear that much about and
and truly like 50% of our species have
gone extinct in like the last 50 years
or something like well it's not just to
correct that it's not species extinction
it's the the total number of individual
wild animals pretty much across the
board okay mammals birds reptiles
amphibians is down by more than 50% but
it's a precursor to species extinction
basically you know you reduce the
populations they become more and more
unstable and once you get to a certain
size basically they're you know just on
the slippery slope right it has a
threshold again you can't come back from
that and when you look it becomes
evident when you kind of look at what's
going on in the Amazonian rainforest
right where we're decimating these you
know beautiful ecosystems at the rate of
like one football field a minute or
something like that and that's all going
towards cattle grazing and clearing land
to raise crops for these cows yeah
pretty much right I heard you talk about
the biomass of cows alone like an
exceeding every other animal on the
planet by some ridiculous I tenfold
tiful
right yeah and the biomass so
and that's I think just a striking
symbol you could almost say of how out
of control this system is that the
dominant species by biomass
overwhelmingly on on or its land
surfaces cows and it's completely
consistent I think if if you you know a
lot of people say how could that
possibly be and all you have to do is
think okay mom is the last time I
I drove any distance it doesn't matter
where you are in the world what animals
did you see cows cows cows the
occasional sheep a squirrel maybe you
know a crow more cows you'd probably see
pigs and chickens but they're all inside
you know these can foes were you can't
actually yes that's actually a very good
point so the pigs on earth today
outweigh every remaining wild animal on
land by more than a factor of two it's
great pigs outweigh them all yeah and
you're right we don't see a lot of them
wandering around because they're in K
foes and chickens outweigh every
remaining wild bird by more than a
factor of two so you know it's it's it's
completely out of whack yeah yeah all
right well you're you're a very unlikely
entrepreneur you come from this academic
background you had a very you know nice
situation all set up for you at Stanford
where you were a tenured professor in
biochemistry and genomics right and you
are somebody who had been vegetarian at
least or plant-based for some number of
years you got interested in the
environment and you decided to take this
sabbatical so I'm interested it's a very
interesting journey to get you to
impossible like this evolution and
you're thinking to how you arrived at
this point so walk me through that a
little bit sure yeah well I I was
looking for something new to work on I
mean just want I just I just wanted to
start with a blank slate and that's one
of the great things about the job I had
Stanford is I could pretty much do
anything constructive that I wanted
and and I wanted to pick the most
important problem I could work on as I
said it very quickly became clear that
this is not just the most important
problem I could work on it's
overwhelmingly the most important urgent
problem in the world and once I realize
that I spent some time thinking about
how to do it I made one false start
which is that the first thing I did was
I organized a conference where I wanted
to bring together economists and
environmentalists and food security
experts and so forth to just look at the
hypothetical scenario in which the
entire food system is plant-based and
the question is what are the economic
impacts you know locally and globally
what are the environmental impacts what
are the food security impacts what are
the public health impacts and I
organized that kind of you know bringing
people with no preconceived notions but
with pretty high confidence that the
answer is going to come out it's a win
win win win win on every axis and that
that would persuade policymakers that
this is something to try to achieve well
then I came to my senses and I realized
that you know abundant evidence that a
policy change would be good for the
world
you know rarely makes it happen and we
don't have time or disappointing yeah
yeah I mean just look at all the all the
things we need to do to avoid a climate
catastrophe and I think even you know at
this point most people in the world
including most politicians in the world
acknowledge that this is a very real
serious threat and yet you can't marshal
the political will to even make tiny
steps towards the solution yeah so so
anyway the point being that I did this
kind of academic thing of you know
putting you a bunch of people together
to kind of look at the issues and then I
realized that that was a complete waste
of time and and and that the only way to
change it basically is to accept that
policies aren't going to change fast
enough people's food preferences aren't
going to change fast enough if at all we
need to find a way to meet the huge
demand for these foods with a much lower
environmental footprint and compete in
the marketplace and basically make these
destructive industries go away not by
attacking them but by beating them in
the marketplace the good old-fashioned
American capitalist way what's
interesting about the journey that you
then embarked on is rather than just
trying to come up with a plant-based
alternative that tastes good you took a
very you know biochemistry approach to
solving a very hard problem the hard
problem being what makes me taste like
me like what is it inherent in this food
that we as a culture embrace and love
that creates that that craving or that
desire to continue to eat it like really
getting into the minutiae and the
building blocks of this product to
understand it at a cellular level mm-hmm
yeah well I think that the the starting
point was realizing that you know there
have been for millennia basically or at
least for centuries plant-based foods
that are intended to approximate meats
okay but they do by and large you know
kind of nice try but a pretty crappy job
of it and and it's just not gonna work
you're not gonna you know if you're
competing for meat lovers who are not
looking for an alternative those foods
are good enough for someone who's
looking for an alternative or someone on
vegetarian diet that wants something
vaguely meat like we need to outperform
meat from animals in every way that
matters to meat lovers and I knew we
just don't know how to do this mm-hmm
and we don't really understand what is
the kind of molecular you know
biochemical basis of the craveability of
meat
and but it's an answerable question and
I felt like it's actually an easier
question to answer than a lot of the
kind of big medical problems that I was
involved in working on and others
involved and working on because
basically the things that we eat as Mead
are incredibly complicated as biological
systems but as food you know like it may
have started as a muscle tissue doesn't
need to move doesn't need to produce
energy from simple nutrients it doesn't
need to keep the cell membrane
potentials active and all the kinds of
things that tissue does it just needs to
do a few simple things that are
producing the flavor that consumers love
and the textural properties and I felt
like that's that's a hard problem I felt
it's a hard scientific problem we need
the best scientists we can possibly hire
but it's the most important scientific
question in the world nice I still
believe the question why does meat taste
delicious in molecular terms is by far
the most important scientific question
in the world right now because if we can
answer it and use that knowledge to make
the most delicious crazyville meat
products in the world using more
sustainable ingredients we can save the
world from you know environmental
catastrophe that we're headed toward
right now
so and actually scientists get that and
so when it came to recruiting scientists
we've been incredibly successful in
recruiting awesome scientists because
the the way you recruit a great
scientist is give them a really
important problem that's really
challenging and the best scientists in
the world just you know gravitate toward
that so you put together you have like a
hundred out of three hundred and thirty
employees or something yes we have about
a hundred and ten people in our R&D team
we're actually just about to start
hiring a bunch more people to roughly
double the size of the team and so if
you're a scientist and
I want to work on the most important
scientific problem in the world and you
know directly yeah you know where to go
so the beginnings of trying to answer
this question how does that work well
there varies so there are different
attributes that have different molecular
bases in Mead but focusing on the one
that I think is that most uniquely
separates meat from any plant-based
foods is the flavor and aroma profile
that based on the flavor and aroma
profile irrespective of texture whether
it's just ground up into a mush or or
you know however you want it and
irrespective of what species it comes
from you will recognize as being meat
and not a plant mm-hmm and so that was a
really important question and you know I
had a hypothesis as to what might be
important for that that could have
proven wrong but basically the premise
was it's based on is based on an
observation actually that when you cook
meat something magical happens that
never happens with plants or a veggie
burger or anything like that
which is that there's this dramatic
transformation of the flavor and aroma
profile it goes from being something
very mild flavored with almost no aroma
to something that is has a potent you
know cooked meat flavor and all the
aromas then come with it
and that and nothing like that happens
with a plant I mean you cook broccoli it
gets warmer and mushy er and and you
know maybe a little caramelized or
something like that but meat as a
category does something magical and that
suggested that there was a catalyst
that's catalyzing the chemical reactions
that happen during cooking that produces
explosion of aroma and flavor and one of
the best biological catalysts known is
heme and animal tissues categorically
have a lot higher human sensations than
almost any
plant tissue like 100 or a thousand
times higher concentration so potent
catalyst super abundant in the things we
call meat was you know a suspect and our
R&D team we immediately started working
on on him on day one basically because
it was a suspect but our R&D team did
some experiments over the first few
months it very clearly established that
team is the magic ingredient that takes
simple nutrients that are just like the
things that you would find in vegetable
broth amino acids vitamins sugars and
fats throwing heme and instead of a mild
broth he tastes you get meat mm-hmm and
he ms is is what binds to oxygen in our
red blood cells and carries oxygen to
our respective organs etc it's what
makes red blood cells red yes and I
think it would come as a surprise to a
lot of people to discover that heme
actually also exists in the plant
kingdom yes because we we just
associated so heavily with meat products
yeah absolutely and you associate you
know you it's it's got a very
distinctive red color you don't see that
almost anywhere in plants but yeah every
plant cell and every cell pretty much on
earth requires him because it's part of
the system that cells use to burn sugars
and simple things for energy to react
them without you know well it's it's
it's a downstream part of that but
basically it's part of the system that
generates energy for the cell and so
it's for example the reason that cyanide
will kill you in two minutes is that it
binds to him and shuts down those
pathways right cell depends on for
energy
so yeah it's ubiquitous in nature it's
it's one of the most important molecules
on earth but it hadn't nobody thinks of
auden plants it happened that there was
a particular part of legumes the part
that fixes nitrogen called
that is the one plant issue that really
has a high concentration of heme and
that's because the the nitrogen fixation
kind of chemistry is sensitive to oxygen
concentration so they have to be
buffered and I knew that and so I
actually in the first about year of the
company's existence I I spent a very
large fraction of the money that we had
raised to start the company trying every
which way to figure out how to harvest
root nodules and extract the heme
protein from the root nodules and and
was really the major single major effort
in the company and it basically was a
dead end it got us enough of this heme
protein like hemoglobin that we could do
the experiments to prove that it could
generate the meaty flavors and so forth
but it was never going to be scalable or
economical and and I use this as an
example to people in the company of you
know you've you've given our mission and
the hugeness of it and all the problems
we need to solve to achieve it where we
don't know the answer we don't know the
route we have to do a lot of things that
are risky mm-hmm
you know when you do if you know the
answer it's not an experiment right and
and we have to be quite fearless about
it and not talk ourselves out of what
seems like a good experiment or a good
project just because it might fail
because any good experiment might fail
if they're not failing a pretty decent
fraction of the time you're not taking
you're not bold enough or you're not
doing really interesting stuff so I
remind people of that because it's
really important for people not to be
afraid to take on something that could
even be expensive we spent you know like
half the money that we started out with
pursue pursuing this idea it was my idea
so I can I can acknowledge that it's a
bad idea without hurting anyone's
feelings
on something that ultimately failed and
it won't be the last time and it failed
because extracting an adequate amount of
heme from this root nodule in legumes
became too like cost intensive or labor
and it was just it was multiple first of
all the root nodules inconveniently
live underground okay so I thought I'd
done a calculation that the US soybean
crop in the root nodules contains more
heme than all the meat consumed in the
US and that I think calculation was
correct the only problem is that it's a
very inconvenient place for that stuff
to to live because you have to dig up
the soil these things are loosely
adherent to the roots of the soybean
plant so you have to it's kind of a
fragile system now you when you do that
you have a bunch of dirt with root
nodules embedded in it and you'd have to
separate out the root nodules and in
order for it to be food safe and and
then you have to biochemically purify
the heme protein and you concatenate all
those steps and it basically becomes
extremely difficult to scale and
expensive on top of which you know from
an environmental standpoint it's not a
good idea to be turning over the soil
because it releases you know carbon
stored in the soil and so forth so there
were there are a bunch of reasons why
you know I ultimately came to the
conclusion that this was not a good idea
and so we moved to producing it by
fermentation and and that's how we
produce it now right so it's through a
genetically modified yeast correct is
that is that how it works yeah so
basically I knew that we could I knew
that we could produce it by fermentation
by just introducing the gene for this
plant protein into some organisms like
yeast it wasn't clear how economical
would be just that it would certainly be
more economical than then digging these
root nodules
on the ground and and so we pursued that
route and we then one interesting thing
that that opened up is that well we
don't need to just use soy leg
hemoglobin we can just look at all the
interesting heme proteins that we know
of and try a bunch of them because given
this approach it's basically just we can
pop the gene in for whatever he and
protein seems the best and and produce a
lot of that for our use and we looked at
like three dozen different Ian proteins
neem proteins from everything from
Paramecium to mung bean to barley bovine
myoglobin which is the heme protein
that's in beef etc and what we were
optimizing for was the one that
performed best in food and and people
often say well why didn't you just use
bovine myoglobin well the cow did not
evolve to be delicious did not evolve to
be food okay evolution was not selecting
was not optimizing the cow for you know
the or team protein for performance and
food and it's really not very good for
that purpose it oxidizes very readily
it's it's got a narrower solubility
range and so forth so ultimately after
looking at a bunch of heme proteins
including one that I loved although it
was never going to be good for food that
was a vivid fuchsia color so it was like
unbelievably beautiful to look at but no
one would probably want to eat it and we
arrived at Soylent hemoglobin which is
the same thing we'd been looking at as
really the best one from a food
standpoint and so we put the solo
hemoglobin gene into yeast and and that
enabled us to produce it at very large
scale right so you don't have to till
the soil in the same way and yes not it
doesn't involve that kind of labor
intensity yes exactly
a different kind of labor and it's and
it's actually a safer way to produce it
because we use an organism that's our
been well-studied for safety for usin
food it's actually even used as to
produce some protein based drugs for for
you know therapeutic purposes and so
forth so the FDA and the regulatory
agencies you know have already kind of
scrutinized it and basically know this
is this a safe system where as a root
nodule who knows what's in there so
there's more question marks um the other
thing is that the yeast have their own
system for producing heme they they make
their own heme and the heme itself which
is a small molecule a cofactor it's a
little a little nugget of a molecule
that's that's held by the protein which
keeps it soluble and sort of protects it
against off reactions and so forth yeast
makes its own heme and so in terms of
heme production all we did was we kind
of like amplified up its own genetic
system for producing heme and then and
then gave it this soybean protein to
hold on to the heme so are the nodules
themselves red or is it just because the
heme is in such low concentrations that
these things these plants that have heme
in them don't appear to be red no
actually the nodules are vivid red are
they are yeah you cut open a root nodule
in sort of early summer when this sort
of the peak growth of soybean plant you
cut it open and it looks like you just
cut open a steak I could show you I
could show you pictures of it literally
take a close-up of it you might mistake
it for a freshly sliced steak Wow
and but you know no other part of the
plant has that kind of high
concentration and yeah which is why it
was so tantalizing to me because you
know you you look at these things when I
first start realized that we needed a
heme protein well I didn't realize then
that we needed it but I was kind of
suspicious that we would I looked at him
you know literally one of the very first
things I done this project was I pulled
up some clovers from a little hill
that's that's in my neighborhood and
and pull up a bunch of them and then
just cut up cut up the root nodules
basically just cuz I wanted to see for
myself you know is there really a lot of
Heymann there and they're bright pink
Wow and yeah so it was very tantalizing
to me that oh man these things are like
practically for free cuz no one's using
them for anything yeah well no one it
hadn't even occurred to anyone to even
look in that direction there are
actually it's interesting there are
soybean farmers who've been growing
soybeans their whole life that have no
idea that the that they're bright red on
the inside yeah it's super interesting
so you figure out this team thing and
then how do you figure out the rest of
what ultimately becomes the impossible
burger the other ingredients to create
that kind of texture and the way that it
cooks and the aroma and everything else
that you know is necessary for you to
deliver on your promise well we're still
in the process of we're still trying to
understand how meat works better and
better all the time but we knew
relatively early on some of the features
of the the proteins responsible for
texture that we needed to match so we
don't we don't need to use identical
proteins there's nothing you know the
the proteins in muscle tissue again they
didn't evolve to produce any particular
texture juiciness it's just an
incidental property that when you cook
them which they didn't evolve to be
cooked you know they they undergo a
textural transformation and they leak
some juice and stuff like that so we
sort of understood what by studying me
we understood what were the salient kind
of biophysical properties of a protein
that we needed you know to produce those
characteristics the textural change with
cooking the juiciness finding the
the chewiness yes the cohesion and then
fats there are also things about the
fats that are important to understand
because the fats are important from
mouthfeel they're important for the
cooking properties because the the
melting fat contributes the cooking and
they kind of like you know bubbling so
to speak
kind of just disperses the aromas and so
forth and because most of the flavor
molecules that confer meaty flavor are
fat soluble it literally is kind of a
delivery system for for those molecules
to produce the taste so but you've got a
to knit right you can't just use any
random fat to get those properties right
so anyway they're a bunch of a bunch of
properties that we you know identified
that were important and then needed to
find a plant-based way to match them so
you arrived at you're using potato right
and coconut oil are the other two main
things coconut and sunflower oil I think
they're I I'd have to look roughly
equivalent amounts so sunflower so the
sunflower oil contains a lot of
unsaturated fats and they participate in
the flavor chemistry the coconut oil
modulates the melting temperature which
is important for mouthfeel and some of
the cooking behavior the potato protein
is there because of textural property
that confers so we you know not just any
random protein will will match the
characteristics that we need so we
searched a lot of plant proteins to
define the right one I found the potato
protein we found some others but the
potato protein was there was a readily
available supply chain for we actually
found some other proteins that from a
performance standpoint and and in many
ways are better
but there didn't exist to supply to you
for them we're actually in the process
of trying to create a supply chain for
some of there's better plant proteins
that are potentially more scalable and
actually better performing so this is a
process of constant iteration this is
the decisive advantage that we have over
the incumbant technology it's that the
cow stopped getting better at what it's
doing
you know million years ago and we get
better every single day and when we can
make product whatever product that's as
good as the best version that ever came
from an animal a week later we can make
it even better and and this is just the
way this this is you know the advantage
of a technology shift you can say that
the parallel would be in transportation
the first mechanized transportation
system famously lost a race to a horse
okay there's a locomotive and in 1835 I
think yeah but but the point is it never
lost again because the horse never got
any faster uh-huh and you switched to a
technology platform that gives you the
ability to optimize every important
feature of it and continue to optimize
it and that's what we've done is that
you know if we identify some flavor
component that we think makes our
product better we can dial it in
immediately right or or find a way to
make the texture juicier or whatever is
desirable there and and that's a huge
advantage and also the economics and the
nutritional profile and so forth so you
know we don't have cholesterol we have
lower saturated fat we have actually
slightly higher quality protein in terms
of essential amino acids and a whole
bunch of things that that consumers care
about right in addition to all the
geniuses and PhDs that you have on your
R&D team do you bring in people that are
expert in taste kind of like how a
fragrance company have these people with
these special noses that can smell
things that ordinary people can't like
how do you evaluate taste in a
scientifically good question and it's
also a really complicated question so
for one thing you know everybody has
their own notion of what the you know
ideal burger tastes like or the ideal
steak tastes like and so forth so
there's not like an agreed-upon target
that's just something important to keep
in mind because our goal is not to
perfectly match the cow version it's to
outperform it in flavor and everything
that consumers care about and we have
people who are trained tasters that can
can give us and the trained tasting is
not only kind of like they've trained
their ability to discriminate particular
features you know in in a food product
in this case meat but also they've
they've been trained on a particular
vocabulary for communicating that huh
because that's that's almost equally
important is that you know you can't
just make up your own brand understand
what metaphor is or something like that
it's not it's not useful and it gives
you away then you can you can more
objectively measure your progress you
know in a particular direction so we do
use trained testers we also rely heavily
on testing where we get one or two
hundred can just random consumers who
are meat-eating consumers from the world
and we ask them to rate our you know
each version that we're trying out on
flavor and texture and appearance and
overall likeability and so forth because
that's also very important yeah in other
words we're not trying to employees
these highly trained tasters we want to
please as many consumers as possible
yeah so that's really important
and then we also use analytical
instruments that give us very
quantitative and objective measurements
of sort of the chemical composition of
the aroma and flavor and where we've
annotated a lot of the compounds based
on their how they smell and what they
contribute and so forth and that enables
us it's more agile than bring 100 people
together in a room to test you know oh
you know a bunch of prototypes that
you're looking at it's no substitute but
it kind of gives you a surrogate measure
to tell you if you're going in a good
direction yeah in addition to heme what
have you discovered that people deemed
to be the most important aspect of what
makes a burger a burger like when you
pull these people and you know try to
learn you know what's working and what's
not working what is it that people come
back to you and say is it texture is it
aroma is it the after case like what how
have you iterated on that kind of
feedback yeah well the thing is that
it's almost it's almost not that useful
to figure out which is the most
important because they're all important
and unless you do a good job on all of
them people will be dissatisfied with
uh-huh
but yeah the the flavor the aroma you
know during cooking the the texture the
specifics of the texture the chewiness
the juiciness the appearance is really
important mm-hmm
I would say the and we're constantly
optimizing all of them you know my own
view about which one is the most
important I mean it just changes all the
time based on what we're focusing on but
I think you know if the color were off
and the flavor and texture were good it
wouldn't win the competition with the
cow if the flavor and color were good
but the texture was mushy we wouldn't
win if we didn't need all the flavor
if it didn't have the right meeting
aftertaste
you have to fire on all cylinders and
it's interesting to think like it's
really important what the room smells
like when you walk into the kitchen and
somebody's cooking it's not just what it
tastes like in your mouth it is the
entire 360 degree experience of working
with this product I mean one thing that
so early on when we were just getting
ready to commercialize it we were giving
samples of our product a lot of chefs
okay that you know work kind of meat
gurus and and a recurring thing that
would happen is they would cook with it
and they would say this just blows my
mind okay why why would that be it's
because there's something magical that
happens when you cook a meat and it's a
it's a big part of I think the pleasure
that chefs get with it that there's this
transformation of flavor there's an
explosion of aroma it's it's and it's
something that you never get with a
veggie burger and we're gonna plant
based product or anything like that so
it's kind of like it's mystical and
magical
it's a magical experience I think and
and the language that that people and
chefs use when they do it you know it's
a very commonly that I mean literally
it's like this blows my mind I've heard
that multiple times and you need to blow
people's mind because meat the behavior
of meat when it cooks is it's it's you
know it's just basic chemistry but it's
magical in the sense that you know this
transformation happens you can also it's
also the fact that you know you have to
be able to cook it to your liking
yeah again something you can't do with
veggie burgers so you know we had to
have the only thing that married for our
product is that it has to deliver from
meat lovers we don't care about anyone
else like I'm vegan you know many people
I love our are entirely plant-based but
we don't care about them from a consumer
standpoint
it's all about delivering for the meat
lover and and we can't kid ourselves you
know we have to deliver what they care
about and and the experience of cooking
is a big part of it and the versatility
so they may want to serve it as tartare
well it has to behave as tartare has to
have that raw meat tastes as tartare
they may like it to cook there their
burgers very rare well it has to not
only look but the texture and the
juiciness and the flavor has to match a
rare burger and if it's well-done it has
to mention well-done burger and you're
not going to solve that by making a kind
of a pre concocted product that that you
know tastes like a cooked burger but
doesn't have the magic and the only way
you get the magic is by understanding
them kind of biochemistry the but you
know underlying beef flavor and
delivering it and one of the neat side
products that I mean side effects of
that is when you understand how meat
works as a system the problem of
producing delicious meaty flavor gets
simpler you don't have to kind of like
take the you know hundreds of molecules
that make up the aroma
profile of meat and figure out a way to
cram them into a product you just need
simple amino acids two simple
biomolecules that are not only simple
but they're abundant and cheap okay
unlike the fake flavors that go into a
lot of veggie burgers just simple amino
acids vitamins simple sugars unsaturated
fats and a catalyst bang you get the
magic you get all those flavors for free
and you make it sound so easy
well it's actually it's an interesting
thing that you often find when you when
you try to understand in a fundamental
way a system it goes from like it's got
thousands of things going on and
complicated properties but then it turns
out that the underlying magic is
relatively simple and it goes from being
you know a big hairy problem like the
problem of how do we how do we make a
food that delivers everything that me
lovers care about and does a better job
of it than the cow seems kind of like a
big hairy problem and and conceivably
could have turned out to be a big hairy
problem but very often what happens is
when you get down to the fundamentals
and you really know how the system works
it gets much simpler
yeah well that's that's something that
that I stumbled across and in preparing
to speak to you today which is that it's
easy to think of impossible foods as
just the impossible burger but in
reality your company is the value of
your company is in this database that
you've created through the results of
all the science that you put into it
that is really drilled down into how to
make all these different flavors using
plants as a source right that you can
then you know extrapolate on to make all
different kinds of different kinds of
beef products and chicken products and
ultimately fish and dairy and the land
the rest right well first of all the way
I define the value of a company is our
ability to achieve our mission I mean we
were serious by 2035 we want to have
essentially eliminate the use of animals
of food technology by beating them in
the marketplace and of performing for
consumers okay and and that really does
come down to building the know-how so
that you have the capability of
producing enough of the products that
that that meat lovers crave and making
them better than then the corresponding
animal derived product that you can win
in the marketplace yeah and and succeed
and yes a lot of what puts us in the
position to be able to do this is why I
would say pretty much most of it is just
the knowledge that we've been
accumulating and you know we're doubling
almost doubling our R&D team sign
because we don't we're not kidding
ourselves okay they're still there's
still a lot of hard problems to solve
ahead we've figured out a lot of things
about you know all kinds of meat flavors
fish flavor you know how to control
texture and juiciness and stuff like
that but we're not at a point where
every meat lover is basically saying I'm
never getting anything but an impossible
burger and I mean although plenty of
them do but and until we get to that
point we're not done and we have to be
able to get better in flavor and aroma
at juiciness at texture and also another
very important thing is that we have to
beat the incumbent products on cost yeah
but that comes with scale it comes with
scale but it doesn't come automatically
with scale it you have to have a system
that asymptotically is much less
expensive and then and then with scale
you you win there but you have to make
the right choices you have to have
ingredients that are inherently scale of
all you have and and where the you know
the economics of those ingredients work
out and and that's something that we
spend a lot of time on it's also really
important for food security I mean you
know part of our goal is to improve
global food security by basically making
you know right now meat is one of the
most important sources of protein and
iron in the global diet protein
deficiency and iron deficiency are
probably the two most common nutritional
deficiencies in the world there's almost
a billion people are protein deficient
almost two billion people are iron
deficient in the world mostly in the
doodlenet core parts around the equator
and and that's a huge problem and making
a product that you know American
consumers will buy doesn't solve the
problem for them so and and and
asymptotically so the
ingredients that we've chosen now based
on their underlying economics we should
be able to be much cheaper when we're at
scale right and I think that's that's
incredibly important even in the
developed world because consumers are
price sensitive if we have a product
that delivers on flavor you know how it
performs in flavor nutrition and it's
cheaper it's game over
right and so that's all of those are
important goals and and we see many ways
to improve on all those axes you know
going forward with our research and also
because the other reason that we've
built this big team is that we don't
want to do it methodically over a long
period of time we want to solve a lot of
problems fast and in parallel and that
have to do with every aspect of making
the product better the products better
and be able to launch a bunch of new
products where you know one of the
things that over the next couple of
years we're going to really build up is
is work on a whole bunch of other
products that we want to launch you know
in the next few years yeah there's been
some press about the fish yeah fish for
sure
I mean fish I would say in terms of
environmental impact you know it's a it
you can debate it but I would say beef
is number one the overwhelmingly the
land footprint of animal agriculture is
cows like I said they outweigh every
remaining wild animal on earth by factor
of 10 and but fish I would say is
probably a close second because you know
the global fish populations are down by
half the demand still out ways the
ability of the population to kind of
reproduce themselves and so that's a
really urgent problem to solve and we're
working on it and you know we've made a
huge amount of progress on fish flavor
we are going to be working over the next
couple of years hard on
getting textures right hmm because
there's different textural properties of
fish tissues and yeah that's that's
gonna be really important you've made
some really interesting choices as a
brand in terms of how you've launched
this product and introduced it to the
public and there are similarities in the
way for example you know Tesla began by
having this aspirational very high-end
product that created a bunch of demand
and then slowly over time building scale
around it to create products that are
more affordable and I thought it was
fascinating that you've mentioned
earlier introducing the product to some
of these high-end chefs like David Chang
being you know probably the most
prominent of them to get it into the
hands of these you know people that we
kind of revere culturally who are taste
makers and our influencing culture and a
pretty you know in a substantial way to
get them on board and then get everyone
talking about what's happening which is
very different from we have this product
like let's get it into grocery stores as
soon as possible and make it as
affordable as possible to everybody so
walk me through the thinking behind how
you've positioned the branding of this
and and how you're introducing this to
the public okay so I would say when we
launched and still today the most
important thing we get from every sale
of our product is awareness of our brand
and and you know and a change in
psychology that plant-based products
don't suck as meat the biggest obstacle
that we saw to our success is that every
meat-eater has a very strong and this is
true now very strong preconceived notion
that it is not possible to make a
plant-based product that delivers what
they crave for meat and and that meant
that the most important miss the most
important thing we need to accomplish
with each sale is to maximally send the
mess
that this is something that if you're a
meat lover you will actually like to eat
and so the most effective way to send
that message is if someone whose
livelihood and reputation depends on
serving their consumers great food and
great meat in particular because the
chef's that we were particularly working
with our people who are particularly
revered as meat chefs okay Dave Chang
famously a few years ago banned
vegetarian items from his menu right
okay he's a meat god and and those are
the people that we we wanted to work
with and if he's willing deliberately on
his own
to put something on his menu and sell it
as meat and a meat application that's
hugely valuable as an endorsement to us
and when we launched we had very limited
production capacity our entire you know
factory so to speak was probably not
much bigger than your garage and so we
had a very small supply and we wanted to
get the maximal bang for the buck out of
every sale I think it was probably I
don't really know the the history behind
Tesla's you know go to market approach
but I think it was probably similar in
the sense that they had limited
production capacity and the most
important thing they needed to achieve
with every sale was not the pittance of
money that they get from the sale it's
the brand building value right creating
an experience that exceeds all
expectations
exactly and then when we were able to
increase our capacity we've still
focused on foodservice because it is a I
would say a much more on a per sale
basis much more effective way of
exposing consumers to our product right
for one thing the restaurant has a stake
in curating the experience and making
sure that the way it's presented to you
is delicious okay and the way a sleepy
you know overworked person coming home
and slapping something on their their
you know in a pan isn't necessarily
going to be able to do so we want
people's first experience ideally to be
in a situation where someone's done a
good job preparing it the other thing is
that you're more likely to be eating in
a group if you're in a restaurant at
least most people are so more people can
get exposed to it by sharing and and and
the restaurant is doing more to advocate
for the product than a grocery store a
grocery store there's 50,000 attendees
on this line
so so anyway it was I think a very
sensible strategy and you know we
haven't done the control but I think it
worked no I think it I think it was a
brilliant strategy and and kind of in
line with that you you guys have always
made sure to protect the impossible
brand within the context of the
restaurant like it's not they're not
serving there you know they can call it
whatever they want they serve have to
use the word impossible in it right like
whether you're an umami burger or Burger
King it's the impossible whopper right
so yesterday I kind of keep that
foothold it's interesting though because
what happened was from a very early
stage we established at least within the
restaurant and kind of food hyperaware
community impossible as a very strong
brand most of the world and most of the
u.s. still hasn't heard of it okay but
what that means is that they get value
from it that it means something to a
consumer that this is an impossible
burger and not just some random veggie
patty so we don't we have no power over
them so most of our sales basically are
just a restaurant decides they want to
put it on their menu they buy it from a
distributor we can compel to zero
Julie obligating them to use your name
know with but but but the thing is it's
greatly to their advantage it's like you
know if you go to a restaurant and
basically they sell beer
full-stop or wine or you know some
no-name coffee or whatever you don't you
don't expect it to be as good and you
probably as much for it if it's got a
brand that means something it's more
desirable to consumers so so we don't
have to compel the restaurant tourists
to do it and we can't and we don't but
they see the same value to it they lose
all the value of the brand that we've
been building if they just put it on
there anonymously yeah I mean we've all
had the experience of going into random
restaurant XY or Z and you order the
veggie burger or the veggie patty and
some nondescript you know hockey puck
kind of thing versus oh they have the
impossible burger and this is something
that you know you can only get in a few
places which kind of increases intrigue
and and and and you know consequently
demand yeah yeah
so anyway so we've we've been I mean we
put a lot of effort into how we launched
to really focus early on not on
generating revenue but generating
positive brand awareness and so forth
and that that has created the incentive
for restaurants to put on the menu as a
branded product which kind of becomes a
positive feedback loop and and it's
going to help us when we launch in
retail because you know at least a lot
of consumers who've had our products in
restaurants and or know about it and and
recognized as a meaningful brand and
something that they they like will seek
it out in yeah in grocery stores in a
way that if it was just some whatever a
generic thing it you know it would be
the best thing in the in the meat
department but but there'd be no way of
people pretty good yeah yeah well the
gradual rollout yeah I think it
definitely has as fed in
- you know intrigue and interest and
what you guys are doing I remember when
you could just I think mommy burger was
the only place in LA where you could get
it except for crossroads or maybe one or
two other yeah I think those were the
first two right and now slowly you know
it's becoming you know it's not
ubiquitous yet but you're seeing more
and more places you guys have raised 750
million dollars or something like that
to date and you're now in how many
restaurants 9,000 10,000 I would say
it's either 10,000 are approaching
10,000 and by the time this is out will
be at national and Burger King they have
about 8,000 aha restaurants so add about
8,000 - how many were in now and and
then we have other young White Castle
we have White Castle we have Red Robin
we have a lot of other really great
burger chains fat burger in the LA area
you know mommy burger uh-huh and you're
doing like a sausage product with Little
Caesars also yes so we have we have
actually an amazingly delicious sausage
product that I mean it's people are
crazy about it and we did our first kind
of test launch with Little Caesars we're
talking to quite a number of other
customers about about launching it in
various form factors on pizza or as a
breakfast patty or things like that and
it really is incredibly good Wow
we've got to try it yeah I haven't tried
that yeah yeah so here we are I presume
that Burger King then becomes your
biggest customer they have to be right
yes yeah and they're huge
internationally right so I would imagine
there's plans for you know I don't know
if you can speak to that but ultimately
some kind of international roll out with
them meanwhile you have you know beyond
meat aligning with Carl's jr. and you're
seeing this kind of coalescing of the
fast-food industry
you know kind of canvassing what's
available on the plant-based meat sector
it's undeniable that this is a growing
trend it's only going to continue to
grow I mean the you know there's varying
reports on what the market cap is here
but it's in the you know it's in the I
don't know six hundred billion dollars
or something like that they're
projecting in the next decade so it's
not going away
that's good yeah I don't know I mean I
probably have that will be able to pay
out some crazy numbers well I think that
there there is one number that's worth
keeping in mind is that right now the
global market for foods made using
animals is about a trillion and a half
dollars ah and by 2030 is projected to
be three trillion dollar global market
so there's plenty of money to sustain
you know to sustain this industry and
and and that's important because you
know we need to scale fast yeah and and
you know scaling fast basically you have
to spend ahead of your growth to get
production and and and every you know
supply chain etc so this is why it's
it's it's this is why we've raised a
bunch of money because because you need
that for for being able to scale but I
think the thing that we're just at the
beginning of what I think will be just a
continuing and probably accelerating
surge toward plant-based products
replacing animal derived products and
there's so many interesting things
behind that first of all the the the
reason that it's kind of been just a
totally marginalized thing until very
recently is to be frank the products
from a mediators perspective a just
slightly sucked and and this is even
true of dairy products and other stuff
is that they're just not there yet but
they will they're getting better all the
time there's a lot happening you know to
make these products not just
incrementally better but vastly better
consumers perceptions are
correspondingly changing from thinking
okay it's a plant based product I'm not
even gonna try it because it's going to
be terrible we actually you should watch
this there's this
there's this radio show no it said I
don't even know what it is because I
never actually watched it but someone
sent me the link of this guy Glenn Beck
he's a right-wing grind it kind of guy
his producer kind of pranked him by and
his sidekick by giving him hopped out he
is that one of the chains that sells our
product in Texas they're very big in
Texas very good chain actually made
great burgers and gave them to hot doggy
burgers one was made with the cow the
other was made with the impossible patty
and came up lying to us and asked him
okay which is which and he and a psychic
kicked it around and eventually they
said well this is a pretty good pretty
good try but this is clearly the one
made from the cow and that was
impossible you got it wrong and and then
and then he was kind of carrying on
because he's a rancher he's a Texas
rancher and you know raises his own beef
cattle and stuff like that and etc etc
etc but but basically the point is those
kinds of things we're we're people who
are absolutely uncompromising meat
lovers are basically realizing that this
is actually really good isn't yeah and
it's getting better I think there's a
positive feedback loop here and we'd
also learn something really interesting
in in talking to meat lovers they don't
love the fact that their meat comes from
animals this is a really important point
meat lovers love their meat because it's
delicious good source of protein and
iron convenient affordable in spite of
the fact that it's made from the cadaver
of an animal meat lovers almost almost
universally it doesn't matter where in
the country or the world do not consider
the fact that this is made from the
cadaver of an animal to be part of the
value proposition it's actually a
negative it's not enough of negative to
outweigh all the positives of the
sensory pleasures they get from it but
but what it means is that if you focus
on in plant-based products delivering
the things that are important to
consumers deliciousness being
overwhelmingly the number one but
nutritional value and affordability you
when you're not at a disadvantage
advantage I think that's right although
I would say that there is a caveat to
that which is you know I don't know how
large this sector of the population is
but there is a swath of people who who
have an emotional connection to the meat
that they eat and it's infused with like
gender politics what it means to be a
man and be masculine and that has a lot
to do with meat even if they're getting
it at the grocery store you know they're
barbecuing at at home and there's
something about that emotionally or
sociologically that I think still you
know it needs to be redressed I mean
ultimately I think we yeah none of us
like the fact that an animal has to die
for our food but there's still that
thing I think that's much more fragile
and superficial then then people give it
credit for and you know 200 years ago
you could have said the same thing about
the horse right I mean even more so
because it wasn't just that it came from
a cow in some farm a thousand miles away
and you're somehow emotionally connected
that animal in this case basically this
is an animal that you live with every
day and you you're taken care of and so
forth and as part of the household and
you would have said wow you know yeah we
have motor vehicles but but we got this
emotional attachment to the horse ah ah
that's gonna be a no it took about a
decade for the for the automobile to
completely flip from you know ninety
percent horses to 90 percent automobiles
in households because what they really
cared about was not that you know
they're the power in their
transportation had four legs and a tail
and and ears it was that it made the
vehicle move and what meat consumers
really care about ultimately is that
it's as delicious as it can possibly be
it has the nutritional value they care
about and you can do what you want to do
with it and so forth I think that that
you deliver that you you outperform in
the things that consumers care most
about and and I think we'll we'll find
that that
you know association with an animal as
the production system is not valued much
even by the hardest core meat lover and
the association with masculinity I think
that it's just something that's so you
know kind of in some societies sort of
culturally programmed and it can just as
easily be you know with cultural shifts
history well when you when you have a
guy like Glenn Beck you know I mean
that's that's huge we're a certain
sector of the population to see somebody
like that you know kind of get on board
with it and well I wouldn't say that he
became our big supporter but just the
fact he accidentally he accidentally
gave us a way to it yeah and then
there's the video of the the people
coming out of Burger King and you know I
don't know if people have seen that I'll
link it up in the show notes but you
know these consumers who were convinced
that they had just eaten a normal
whopper and we're surprised to find out
that yes and regular regular Burger King
whopper loving customers and yeah and
that's that's really what it comes down
to is you've got to give the consumer
the pleasure and satisfaction that they
need and you know all those sorts of
things and it it becomes a non-issue
that this is made from plans
the reason it's a big issue is that that
people just think it cannot possibly
deliver the things they value from meat
if it's made from plants but that is
that is going to change a lot as
consumers see more and more evidence
that that you know the most delicious
meat in the world can come from plants
right what about the argument that comes
up that protein from animals is superior
to the protein that you get in plants
well I mean first of all it's complete
and there's and there's you
know this is not something that has been
ignored by scientists or anything like
that
there's there's first of all protein a
protein is a class of molecules made up
of a string of amino acids and from a
nutritional standpoint
protein is just it just depends on those
amino acids and particularly the
essential amino acids and their relative
proportions and so forth that's that's
what defines the nutritional value of a
protein there are lots of plant-based
proteins that from the standpoint of the
proportion of essential amino acids are
better than beef and that's you know
that's simple and demonstrable even soy
is one of them then people a lot of
meteors think that there must be some
kind of Hubbard okay maybe it's not the
protein maybe it's something else that
magic ingredient and meat that that you
know you need for optimal health right I
have one or something like that I mean
it's the hormonal content you do not
want more igf-1 I mean if you if you
look for like what are the one of the
strongest markers of you know risk for a
shorter life idea if is one is one of
them but anyway so the point is that
here's the experiment that you should
look at there are people who have never
had meat in their entire lives including
my three kids maybe your kids they're
incredibly smart excellent athletes I
think my son could beat you in a race in
a running race and probably probably an
uphill bike race - because he's
incredible climber I don't know and I
don't want to throw down the challenge
because he's he hasn't been warned well
I invited 52 but ya know that's true -
but anyway but that's not the point the
point is and I think this is something
point that you try to make all the time
that there's no compromise in terms of
your health and nutrition if you have no
meat in your diet right period it's
demonstrable true it's it's there have
been you know there are hundreds of
millions of people that have never eaten
meat in their lives and they're thriving
they
successful professionally they're
successful athletes there they're you
know incredibly smart nothing missing so
it's just a complete myth and also
there's you know lots of reviews in the
in the nutrition science literature that
that just systematically address all the
evidence that not only a meatless diet
but but an entirely plant-based diet is
completely healthy at all stages of life
yeah there's no you don't have to sell
me on that no I know with you but I know
that comes up and it's like yeah yeah
yeah I get it but like you know there's
no protein like the protein that I'm
getting in the animal again this is one
of these myths that I think is is
propagated in part we get some
encouragement from the the industry it's
propagated in part by the desire to
rationalize a strong tastes from the
meat I think that will vaporize very
quickly when there are great plant-based
products when there is more and more
evidence that that people you respect
for all the all the qualities that you
value in yourself are eating an entirely
plant-based diet and and you know it'll
we'll look back on it and just say what
what will we think doing right yeah well
let's talk about the industry a little
bit the big get the big AG industry from
a legislative and regulatory viewpoint
there's some very interesting things
that are happening right now they are
not going to go quietly into the night
so we have everything from you know
famously the ag-gag laws that are
preventing consumers from truly
understanding how these products are
manufactured and packaged and how these
animals are tended to and slaughtered
etc to more recent iterations of
protectionism in the form of for example
this law that just passed in Mississippi
that is from my understanding
criminalizing labeling
a veggie patty a veggie burger as a
veggie burger or you can't even use the
word veggie burger do you describe your
product mm-hmm
do I have that right and like what is it
I honestly I don't know the details the
law but you you have it close enough the
labeling law war here is interesting I
think I think it's a it's a major part
of the current strategy that the
industry is trying to do to throw
roadblocks in the way of plant-based
meats and dairy dairy products and dairy
products although I think that in a ways
that cow has left the barn so to speak
but and I think that I expect those
efforts to continue I think that
ultimately those laws will be found
unconstitutional and they'll certainly
be some court battles over them but I
think it's not it's if if they want it
look if if they said you have to call it
something completely different okay you
have just make up a name that it makes
no reference to meat well people will
not have any trouble figuring it out
right I mean yeah well it's preposterous
that they would the argument that it's
confusing the consumers it's just
ridiculous
no of course they just that's why I
think it's not going to hold up to any
kind of a legal challenge but but but my
point is that even in the I would say
virtually inconceivable but exceedingly
unlikely chance that they that these
laws actually hang on it's not going to
stop you know consumers are not
interested in our products and won't be
interested in our products because of
their name if we have to educate
consumers at this product which you know
we're calling you know amethyst or
whatever is is actually you know
identical in all the ways they care
about to meet only better
it'll be no problem I mean it's this is
it'll just be kind of a minor a
short-term inconvenience call it what
you want it's sitting there in the meat
case you've seen you know chefs cook it
on TV you've eaten it at barbecues you
know what it is okay
what's the big deal yeah people don't
love beef because they love the name
right I never thought about that yeah I
guess that's true right well in order to
actualize this this this mission that
you're on
you have to reach tremendous scale and
you guys are working your way towards
that you've recently had kind of hockey
you know a hockey stick growth that was
almost I would imagine on some level
maybe unexpected because you ran into
some issues with meeting the demand was
so high like you were having trouble
even fulfilling on that and so scale is
like I would imagine one of your huge
focuses right now sure so I mean the
fundamental problem that I think we've
we learned a great lesson when the
demand kind of surged we were preparing
to scale up production
we were already hiring for you know
additional shifts at our production
plant and and designing you know
additional production line and stuff
like that so we knew it was coming but
it just came much faster than I
anticipated
and and that was obviously you know a
big problem because the customers that
are basically what we depend on for our
whole mission and have been incredibly
loyal and you know if in many cases
taking a risk putting our product on
their menu nothing is worse than if
you're in a restaurant business which is
you know kind of dicey business to begin
with and a consumer comes in for
a product that you know is on your menu
and you're out of it I don't have its
you lose that that revenue you lose also
the revenue for all the other stuff that
you would have sold with it you've
alienated a consumer yeah and so first
and good well it's it's terrible and we
I can just tell you it doesn't do any
good we feel terrible about the fact
that any of our restaurant customers
suffered any consequences we did
everything we possibly could which
wasn't enough to to you know try to get
product to our customers while we were
in this deficit situation and then we
just scrambled like while to get out of
it including you know when we when we
saw it coming and also the the thing
about the food distribution system is
that is that the demand signals take a
while to filter back to you uh-huh
because there's these two distribution
nodes between you and the customer so
that there's a delay and then you you
you start seeing that you know the
distributor's your distributors running
out which means the downstream
distributors have been running out to
the restaurants and stuff like that but
anyway when we saw this happening I put
out a call to everybody in our company
that wasn't working in the factory
basically saying we need volunteers and
what we're asking you to do is kind of
like Shackleton Shackleton's allegedly
all yes yes yeah basically we're asking
you to volunteer to go across the bay
which isn't terrible slept but it's an
hour maybe and work 12 hour shifts that
either start or end at 3:00 a.m. at 38
degrees Fahrenheit you know doing not
the science that you signed up to do but
basically stacking burgers or doing
something like that so that we could add
additional shifts and and catch up to
the demand and within 24 hours a hundred
people had signed up to volunteer to
work or any planned and you know for a
time more than half of the people who
were working there over the course of
week we're basically from our R&D team
not the you
people we had hired for the production
team and then we just geared up hiring
like mad and we have to have a high
standard for hiring because you know
we're producing food and it's no joke
you know so anyway bottom line is we
managed to kind of restream now you know
24-hour production with people with you
know experienced faculty factory workers
people with experience in the food
industry and and so now we're catching
up and we in fact we've replenished the
distributors and I think that we're not
gonna let that happen again
but the problem the fundamental problem
is when you're growing you know like
more than twofold a year like really
really growing super fast the the
business of you know you don't know for
sure the slope some of the growth comes
kind of not entirely predictably like
you know we didn't know whether or when
Burger King would sign on as customer
and when they did bang it's a big thing
we you know other big customers sign on
well we can't be producing that amount
when there's no customer but then we
have to suddenly be producing that
amount so we need that agility and we
need to invest ahead of the growth
meaning we need to anticipate while
we're going to be producing the demand
is going to be you know several fold
greater in a year and we have to make
the investment in extra capacity which
you know is quite a big bet and and
since we are going to be doing this you
know every year on average doubling
every year from now until 2035 to
achieve our mission it's gonna be it's
going to be this this is going to be the
challenge all the way long right and
what we've done is we've really changed
the way we plan our business which is
very heavily focused on being prepared
for a wide range of possible
trajectories so that we can be agile if
the demand surges and we if the demand
just stays is expected we're ready for
that
and if there's some reason that the man
goes down we're ready for that yeah it's
a tricky equation because as you grow
and scale the ability to be agile
becomes under threat right so the fact
that you've got to be super
protectionist about the R&D that you're
doing and making sure that you have
avenues in place where you can iterate
and innovate quickly to respond right
well so the some of the responses don't
require R&D innovation they just require
us to do do a lot more of the same thing
that we already know how to do very
suddenly like just scale the existing
production but but the other thing you
are alluding to I think is that that we
need to make products that can compete
on an even playing field successfully
against the products that have been on
the market for a thousand years and win
on their merits and that's a that's a
high bar and we need to do that for you
know all the categories of products that
that are made using animals and or
achieve our mission and and we're going
to do it I mean I'm completely convinced
the more I know about I love the bots
and what's required know the thing is
that because we are in an arms race and
there is a ticking clock here there is
no that 2035 we'd it's not we we picked
a time target because of the urgency of
this and you know of climate change and
the meltdown and biodiversity and so
forth
we can't just you know like you could
say from a business standpoint we could
do the same thing with much lower risk
by just kind of you know slow and steady
growth and so forth we can't we have to
we have to take the risks to you know
grow on the steep curve because that's
our mission you know and from an R&D
standpoint you know we tell the team
okay sometime in the next few years
we're going to have fish and chicken and
pork and bacon and and melty cheese's
and you know all these different
products that we've spent some time
doing basic research on and so forth but
that's still
to step from you know making a product
that that competes on an even playing
field for a consumer not just nice try
and that's why we're beefing up our an
R&D team but the people who have been in
this for a while and the more you know
about the more confident you are because
you can see the space of possibilities
space of possible solutions you know
better what are the problems you need to
solve and what's likely to be entailed
and solving them before you've solved
them completely and but it's you know
it's it's a big climb yeah it's got to
be exciting though I mean this
trajectory that you've been on from
academia to now sitting atop this two
billion dollar company and having you
know being responsible for hundreds of
people has put you in a position where I
would imagine you had to go on a crash
course learning about leadership and
management and all of these things that
were not part of your professional
experience prior yeah I mean there's
what you're worried about how to run and
build a company I mean yeah you know I
haven't I haven't actually taken a
course and one thing I've I would say
one thing I've learned or one thing I
did that I in retrospect I think was was
an important thing to do was recognize
right away there's a whole bunch of
things that I don't know how to do well
and I don't have time to learn how to do
them so you get Dennis winds would say
idea so I get someone like Dennis and
and suddenly you know I can I I don't
have to I know this is this whole part
of the company is in is in the best
possible hands when I first formed the
company I I felt like well I don't know
anything about the the legal issues and
the the basic blocking and tackling of
building a business okay but I know
where to find people who do and I hired
someone straight our Stanford Business
School very smart guy still working at
the companies ahead of our our
international growth
and he was basically responsible for
doing all the basic doing very well all
the basic stuff of running a business
and and managing the finances and
managing all the business operations I
know how to you know kind of leader at
R&D team but one thing I hadn't done
even there was so Maya my labs research
has always been very kind of like basic
discovery driven sort of research it's
it's a lot of the thought processes are
similar but when you're when when when
you're on a on under time pressure
having to solve specific practical
problems ok it's it's it's a different
set of things like when when we were
first operating I ran the the R&D like
an academic lab basically which was the
only thing I really knew how to do and
but it was the right thing I think by
and large because mostly what we needed
to do first was to study the problem and
and understand what we needed to do and
do the kind of discovery research that
that is like what I used to do when it
morphed into we need to still be doing
all that but now we're trying to figure
out how do we extend shelf life and and
you know solve this packaging issue or
whatever it's it's it's it's got an R&D
ish component but it's it's it's it's
much more practical and it's got time
pressure and and that's something that I
wasn't initially that you know I was
never in a I was never in a position
where the R&D team needed to do
something on a timeline yeah because
that that's just not part of the
academic experience yeah right
yeah and that's something that that but
fortunately again there there there are
people who are good at that that could
both help educate me and and bring that
expertise there in terms of leading a
team I mean I don't consider the thing
is that the company is successful
I think because the basic premise of the
company is right mm-hmm okay and there's
a huge potential there and I think if
you hire great people like literally I
would say the make-or-break thing you
need to get right is to hire great
people and and if you hire great people
then they want to hire other great
people and if you're high great people
are not just smart but great like
they're kind they're great collaborators
you can build a team in a culture that's
incredibly strong and without a lot of
micromanaging by me can you know can
grow itself right and and you attract
those great people by having a huge
mission and giving people interesting
problems to work on but that's it
you can hire mediocre people by offering
a big bucket of money but to hire great
people you have to give them a hugely
important problem that's challenging and
that's what that's what great people
write and have them feel empowered like
they actually you know have the the
agency to work on it
yes exactly yeah and yeah I mean this is
this is your you know this is for the
people wrong at the company their
opportunity to be part of the most
important I really feel like our mission
is the most important mission in the
world right now and arguably the most
important mission in history because the
fate of the planet is in the balance and
we're not going to solve climate change
or this biodiversity meltdown any other
way and actually I'll just say one thing
about climate change even though he
didn't ask me about but there's there's
a very interesting aspect about the land
footprint of animal agriculture which is
the opportunity cost in terms of climate
change mitigation people are talking
about you know here's this very
complicated technology for carbon
capture okay there's a lot of work done
on carbon capture and so forth
very capital-intensive very hard to
imagine how it will ever scale we have
the most scalable the most highly
evolved carbon capture system in the
world right at our disposal and it's
basically all it requires is land water
and sunlight okay
and the we got water and sunlight 50% of
RIT's land area is being used to raise
animals for food the amount of biomass
on that land and it's actually you know
been research on this represents about
17 years worth of fossil fuel emissions
okay meaning that if you could snap your
fingers and make that industry go away
the recovery of biomass on that land
just without doing anything will
immediately start lowering atmospheric
co2 concentrations you don't need fancy
technology you just need to kick the
cows off the land basically and not at
the same time you're going to be solving
this biodiversity meltdown because it's
all about habitat destruction and
degradation and if you allow if you just
if you just get the feed crops and the
cows out of the equation you basically
get back about half of Earth's entire
land area to capture capture carbon from
the atmosphere automatically and and we
build healthy ecosystems so yeah it's
it's it's incredibly compelling and and
it seems unassailable to me but what I
find interesting is you know in the same
way that that big food big AG will not
go quietly into the night and there's a
couple more things I want to say about
that we're seeing this sort of small
groundswell of people who are you know
adopting this carnivore diet and it goes
hand in hand
in some respects I guess loosely with
the regenerative agriculture movement
which I think there's a lot that's great
about that so I'm interested in how yeah
you're shaking your head I mean
hear about this like how what you're
saying kind of squares with people who
are trying to you know reclaim what the
farm is and can be as a means of
regenerating the soil
okay so I've spent a lot I'm looking at
at the literature I've I've dug into the
data and so forth surrounding
regenerative agriculture it's a longer
conversation but what I can say is there
there is zero evidence so that what
happens is that that people are
extrapolating from the wrong kinds of
experiments to say the best thing we can
do is put more cows on the land okay if
you take land that that has been
depleted by farming and you convert it
to growing grass how do you do that well
first of all it involves putting ton of
fertilizer on the land and then you have
cows grazing on the grass what has
worked is is putting fertilizer putting
fertilizer back into the soil the
depleted soil and letting grass grow on
it they give the credit to the cows
there's zero evidence for that okay
second so there's no the idea being the
the core idea being that the cows being
on the land is what's regenerating the
soil right and and honestly you just
have to look into what what the raw
evidence is that sited in favor of that
and there is lots of scientific
literature on this in many many
ecosystems that have looked at whether
this works and there's just no evidence
for it and the other thing is that the
experiments are asking the wrong
question which is the question they're
asking is is is this system instead of
growing you know soybeans or whatever
was going on the land planting grass and
putting cows on it is it better from you
know carbon capture standpoint than
continue to grow those crops the real
question is is it better than a healthy
ecosystem that would otherwise exist on
that land
if you don't support biodiversity on and
store biomass not just in the soil but
above ground and and like I say there
this is one of these things where there
are these these claims being made that
ecologists have no respect for okay but
their claims being made by people who
are in that business and they're just
being repeated over and over again and a
lot of people just think okay well I
keep hearing about this it must be a
good thing but the scientific foundation
of Furth is essentially nil and and if
you think that we'd be better off with
instead of having 10 times the total
biomass of every wild vertebrate on
earth 15 times you know as cows I mean
you're smoking crack it's a it's it's
it's it's just a completely ridiculous
idea now one thing I just want to say is
there are people who are doing this I'm
not questioning their good intentions
you know a lot of people who are in the
farming and ranching business they care
deeply about you know protecting the
planet and and protecting the you know
taking care of the land they farm and so
forth so it's not a question of bad
intentions it's just a question of
there's no data to support this yeah so
so this is this is something that I
think was initially launched into
mainstream awareness by Allan savory I
believe he did a TED talk on this he's a
lot of you know people that are
following him but on a very elementary
elementary level when I look at it I
just can't get around the idea that it's
incredibly land intensive like it's not
scalable like we're not gonna be able to
feed 10 billion people on the planet in
this way there may be a place for a very
high end you know like the Joel
Salatin's and people want to you know
spend a premium amount of money for meat
but in terms of feeding the planet you
need an unbelievable amount of land for
these cattle to graze and we're already
at 50% right there is
that much more land available and where
are like where's the water coming from
like wait I don't you know I don't know
that it accounts for everything and
maybe I'm missing something here but it
just doesn't seem to make sense as a
solution that's gonna work at scale for
a you know a quickly escalating
population of people where we're already
struggling to meet the demand well I
think that the you you hit on the main
thing which is that yes it's incredibly
land intensive forgetting about whether
there's any evidence that this is better
than you know even if you presume it is
virtually anything else but here's the
thing if if instead you allowed the
original biomass that existed on that
land before it was cleared for farming
and grazing and stuff like that to
recover and there are lots of
publications that address what happens
when you when you take a take a land
that's being used to raise cattle and
you you turned into a national park or
State Park and so forth it actually can
recover over a relatively short period
of time a lot of its native flora and
wildlife and so forth but the amount of
carbon that gets stored there okay
instead of just a little layer of grass
that's being continually grazed and so
forth that you have you know trees and
tall grasses and all this biomass that's
how you pull carbon out of the
atmosphere not by having cows you know
stamped around some different soil yeah
and anyway I don't even want to get it
you know this is one of these debates
where it generates a lot of heat and
it's it's I'm always kind of even though
there's nothing nothing to that you know
I gotcha a culture thing yeah I don't
want to get too much into it because it
it it it alienates people who are trying
to do the right thing but but and the
way that we achieve our mission is not
by winning arguments it's by focusing
relentlessly on making the most
delicious and meat in the world and
letting it speak for itself right on
that subject
I think it's safe to say that Wall
Street is paying attention the beyond me
IPO was massive and now we're seeing you
know big players move in to the sector
we've got Nestle Tyson Perdue all of
these giant conglomerates are
recognizing that this is the future and
they're stepping in to you know they're
starting to enter your space here so how
do you think about that and you know I
honestly here here's how I think about
it if if someone who is a current
mediator decides that they would rather
eat something made by Nestle or whomever
a plant based product my filling is
congratulations that's great keep eating
that we're going to go after the people
who are not satisfied with that product
because that's where the action is and I
think that it will be up to them to make
a product that really reaches into the
meat consumer market which is the VAT
vastly greater than the veggie burger
market let's say and and those consumers
are you know are not looking for another
veggie burger they're looking for meat
yeah that delivers what they get yeah
yeah is a big distinction there and and
so if if those guys can come up with
something that really performs for meat
lovers then my filling is thank you for
doing this you know it feeds your
mission where yes exactly what it does
is the the problem is something else
which is that if there's a lot of hype
and and the products don't deliver which
is kind of my concern it reinforces the
biggest obstacle to trial of our product
which is the strongly held notion that
nothing made from plants can possibly be
good as meat and
a bunch of these big companies put a lot
of hype behind a product that's
basically just a glorified veggie burger
make sure John murder it just makes our
job hard yeah but but we are not
interested in competing with and that's
the most important point is that that
their success we don't want their
customers we want the customers who are
not satisfied with their product you're
making a Maserati and they're gonna
churn out Toyota Corolla I think it's
more like a Tesla but yeah okay yeah no
I get that what's going on with
McDonald's why are they like the last
all these fast food chains are getting
on board here one by one McDonald's
seems to be biding their time here do
you have any sense of what I don't know
what's going on in their heads I think
historically they they move at a very
deliberate pace and making any kinds of
decisions or such a big so so big at
scale it it for them I think the
robustness of your supply chain is
really important you know they they need
to have guaranteed access for product at
scale you know at a very large scale and
so forth so there's a lot of a lot of
things that that are a bigger deal for
them than for almost anyone else well
Burger King is is is pretty close but
they're they're actually incredibly
agile they are they've really impressed
me they're they're they make decisions
quickly
they make them well they do they really
do their homework they're very
analytical and and I think they
recognize that this was a big
opportunity that that they didn't they
wanted to get it right they were very
methodical and looking at the
alternatives when they were deciding
what to you know to put a plant based
product on their menu but once they did
they moved
quickly yeah yeah one thing I need to
ask you about is is something you've
been transparent about which is that you
you use GMOs in your product so how do
you speak to that or speak to the person
who has wariness around you know that
issue which is a sensitive issue for a
lot of people I think the most important
thing is we do speak to them about it
and we engage in any conversation answer
any questions they have about it
we are extremely candid even to the
point of you know kind of being out
there about making sure that people know
that we have product you know products
in our ingredients that product there
that are produced by genetic engineering
and what I found is that basically
consumers when they understand what's
actually being done and I've had
probably a thousand of these
conversations where someone you know has
this concern is there something I should
be worried about and if you just talk
them through it and they understand
exactly what we're talking about here
and why we made this decision and why
it's the best decision we could make
it's it's taken off the table as an
issue now I mean I think there are some
people for whom they're absolute
fundamentalists it's basically it
doesn't matter what the scientific
evidence says GMOs are bad inherently
and and I'm not even interested in
listening but for most consumers that's
not the case and the other thing to keep
in mind is that products made by genetic
engineering are ubiquitous in the food
system I mean you know more than half of
all that cheese in the u.s. is produced
using rennet which is normally an enzyme
in the stomach of baby you know cows but
it's actually produced by yeast that
have been engineered with the cow gene
for for that protein and that's been
true for 25 years
and you know very large fraction
products made from grains are made from
genetically engineered crops if you
drink sodas that corn syrup comes from
genetically engineered corn
so the Jeannette the genetically
engineered aspect of what you do is is
it has to do with the yeast correct like
I just want to understand there's two
components so at first we made the
decision very long before we launched
commercially that we would use genetic
engineering to produce our heme protein
uh-huh because it was by far the safest
most scalable economical way to produce
it and we needed it it was the essential
ingredient for mead so that was no
brainer and recently because of the
surge in demand basically we had
initially been using non-gmo soy right
well there wasn't enough non-gmo soy
market you had to pivot GMO so yes now
is there a reason to be concerned about
that no actually there is not we the
reason we were using non-gmo is because
that was a you know for the low
hemoglobin we had no choice that was the
only way to produce it scalably and and
safely and affordably by genetically
engineering yeast there was us for the
soy protein we didn't need to use the
GMO soy and we felt like well we don't
want to pick any fights we don't need to
we don't need to pick so we'll just use
the non-gmo soy that's existing on the
market and you know we don't need any
additional controversies but now we
needed to scale up and we needed the GMO
soy so the question is and we have a
blog post on this where you can read all
the details but but we had actually even
before I made that decision we looked
hard at it in terms of what are the real
issues so in terms of and for you know I
think the reasons that people are
concerned about unless you are GMO fun
fundamentalist where you basically just
feel like Genji
is bad is the main genetic modification
of soy is resistance to glyphosate right
and and so the reasons for concern are
is this causing more glyphosate use with
greater exposure in the environment or
to workers and so forth to this
herbicide and are there residues on the
on the food that would pose a health
risk to the consumer okay so the total
amount of herbicides used on soy crop
you know the the non GMO soy gets
treated just as heavily with herbicides
and actually more toxic herbicides and
roundup there it's not like the non-gmo
soy doesn't doesn't get herbicides out
absolutely not there's there's good data
on that and and the total burden is very
comparable possibly greater than for the
GMO soy a second thing is if you care
about that issue in our case the
question you should ask is if I buy an
impossible burger will I be worsening or
improving the problem to the extent
exist with with herbicide use well our
herbicide footprint is about 10 times
lower than the herbicide footprint of
beef from a cow because those animals
are fed corn soybeans alfalfa all these
feed crops that are treated with
herbicides and in fact a lot more of
them than our soybeans so for an
environmental standpoint you're way
ahead from a residue standpoint the the
glyphosate residues what we've measured
glyphosate we're just going to have a
blog on this but we've measured the
glyphosate residues in our product and
many times in our earlier version we've
done it since we switched to the GMO soy
we've we've measured twice there's no
detectable
pesticide residues of any kind with a
detection limit that's like thousands of
times lower than the dose at which
there's any health risk thousands of
times giving I mean that would be my
concern is the you know am i ingesting
glyphosate and you know yeah you know I
do have some concerns about that so well
I think it's legitimate to be concerned
and aware of it but I think that the
thing to consider is for example the the
detection limit of the assay we use if
it detected something it's it's like I
think a couple of hundred times below
the level that's allowed in organic
soybeans okay
so there is and and by the way I'm one
of the good reasons for doing what we're
doing is reducing the herbicide the
pesticide footprint of the food system
so our our you know pesticide footprint
so to speak is like tenfold lower than
then the cow okay so it's not that you
know were we're indifferent to it but in
terms of consumer exposure the the a
quite high fraction of organic foods
have measurable levels of glyphosate
just because it's kind of you talk with
us and but it's far below the level at
which there's any any toxic effects like
maybe ten thousand tons of low level in
which you could be exposed with every
single day for your entire life without
any health consequences so again I'm not
advocating for the herbicides but people
freaked out about these things when if
they actually knew what the data said
they wouldn't worry yeah I got you so
good i'll well i'll link that initial
blog post you mention we post notes if
there's another one let me
Noi yeah yeah all right cool
well I gotta let you go here in a few
minutes but walk me through okay you
it's it's 2035 we've eradicated cows on
the planet we have you know introduced
plant-based meats and meat alternatives
and dairy alternatives to the global
population what does the world look like
welcome through the the the successful
vision of this mission so if we don't
succeed if it's business that you as
usual we are going to be doing the
basically late stages of biodiversity
meltdown and you know catastrophic
climate change and so forth if we
achieve our mission which we will we
will be far along in restoring healthy
ecosystems and that support biodiversity
because the 50% of its land area that's
being used to raise animals for food can
recover its biomass and its wildlife and
you know biodiversity secondly we will
have turned back the clock on climate
change will have reduced ongoing
emissions by at least 15 percent and
will have been will have turned back the
clock on climate change by at least 17
years so how far in the future is 2035
that's okay Steen you so basically
basically we will have put a significant
halt to progression of climate change
and these are you know this may sound
like hype but you can just do the math
this is not you know a made-up scenario
the recovery of biomass on the land
that's being used for agriculture will
pull 17 years worth of carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere just by
photosynthesis and growing the plants
and yeah so I think we'll have a more
livable planet
we'll have averted climate catastrophe
will a vastly reduce
the demands on the water supply water
security because it's like about third
of all water use waterways will have
much less nutrient pollution we won't
have dead zones in in river deltas which
is all due to agricultural runoff and
lower risk of foodborne illnesses lower
risk of influenza epidemic because those
influenza epidemics that are the biggest
fear of public health professionals
almost invariably start in poultry farms
and or pig farms and get rid of those
farming situations the risk of a new
epidemic strain of influenza goes way
down also the antibiotic intake of all
the people that are eating oh yes
that's right yeah the antibiotics not
the antibiotic intake because you don't
get much antibiotic residue from me the
problem is that the mass amount of
antibiotics that are being fed to
livestock select in in those animals
bacteria many of which are can infect
humans that are resistant to those
antibiotics so we're breeding the
superbugs your breeding superbugs and
yeah so that is kind of like the system
that is sort of like the optimal thing
you could possibly do create this huge
culture of bacteria where you're
selecting for antibiotic resistance on a
massive scale
yeah you'll get rid of that reduce the
reduce the risk of multi drug-resistant
bacteria getting into the human
population it's a pretty good list it's
one of these things where I mean to me
it almost sounds ridiculous when you
list all the advantages of it like how
could that possibly be that well it's
because we're so used to this system
that we don't realize how catastrophic
'le bad it is for Public Health for the
environment you know it's hard to
telescope out and see it for what it is
it's almost like you have to be if you
were I've said this before but if you
were an alien and you landed on planet
earth and you said take me to the people
who make these decisions about how
you're making your food and who was
explained to them and they looked around
they'd say what do you you're you're
insane
yeah well I the way I think about it is
that you know in 20 years we and
particularly kids will look back on what
we're doing now and just think how could
you possibly have thought this was a
reasonable thing to do like what yeah
what you're literally covering the
planet with cows so you could kill them
and eat them when when you can just make
better tasting healthier more nutritious
food directly from plants like what yeah
I think that's a good place to end it
yeah Thank You Pat okay thank you I
appreciate you talking to you yeah
[Music]